a Donald Trump press release sent out a
few days ago cited conspiracy website
Infowars as a source you might be aware
about Infowars being and Alex Jones run
far right-wing conspiracy theorist
website and YouTube channel if you're
not familiar with Infowars to give you
sort of an idea of the kinds of stories
that they report here are some actual
headlines from the Infowars web site
that i will show you for example 9/11
CIA likely built remote-controlled
commercial jets in aircraft boneyard
another example overwhelming evidence
mounts indicating Colorado shooting was
staged another example government caught
in Boston bombing false flag cover-up
Norway terror attacks a false flag San
Bernardino false flag Brussels attacks
are false flags new world order opening
thousands of portals to ancient demons
Bruno Mars Illuminati halftime show
decoded and the classic that many of you
may have heard of the government and Big
Pharma are turning frogs gay Infowars
genuinely appears to be one of Donald
Trump's favorite media outlets here's
Donald Trump praising Infowars during
the 2016 election I just want to finish
by saying your reputation is amazing I
will not let you down you'll be very
very impressed I hope and I think we'll
be speaking a lot Donald Trump also
tweeting an Infowars article that quote
proves that trumps claim about Muslims
celebrating on 9/11 was true I live in
New Jersey and real Donald Trump is
right Muslims did celebrate on 9/11 here
we saw it Infowars has been one of the
most vocal outlets pushing the narrative
about the non-existent 3 to 5 million
illegal voters for Hillary Clinton they
had an article not long ago saying
report 3 million votes in presidential
election cast by illegal aliens and a
week and a half ago the Trump
administration issued a one-day press
pass to Infowars and now this is sort of
the cherry on top the Trump
administration
citing Infowars in press releases
apparently Trump got so insecure again
about the size of his crowds that he
sent a message to his campaign supporter
email list talking about how Trump
supporters outnumber protesters and at
the bottom of the message they linked to
an info Wars article is this because
Trump wasn't able to find another outlet
with a headline this flattering to his
administration what did it tell you that
Donald Trump has to resort to lunatic
propaganda fringe websites to find
somebody that agrees with much of what
he believes well he clearly can't rely
on his own White House to report the
crowd sizes in Washington DC and our
because when they tried to do with just
the metro numbers that didn't go so well
didn't go he didn't like those numbers
and here's the picture by the way at the
top of the article that Donald Trump
linked to the article refers to the
Paris agreement as a globalist plot
naturally yeah so anyway this this is
new right I mean this is actually I know
we shouldn't pay more attention to info
wars than they are worthy of but Fox
News is nothing compared to info wars
this is basically bottom-of-the-barrel
propaganda website I mean there's
certainly plenty of crossover when it
comes to people who tune into info wars
and Trump supporters I'll say so he has
to give them some sort of dog whistle
and some sort of approval
yeah when a trumpet may be casually
knows about info Wars and then hey I
mean after all it's a Trump press
release that is citing info wars they
must be some kind of legitimate news
source the fact that they were given
that one day pass which you know high
school newspaper reporters can get to
attend a press briefing also doesn't
help even if it was conspiracy theorists
jerome corsi who was allowed in for the
day so this is this is the era that
we're living in today's episode of the
david pakman show is made possible in
part by Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing and
ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not wearing contact lenses I started
with the free at home try
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS